[Music]
my name is Miles Morales and in my world
I'm the one and only spider-man that is
until he showed up and it's a no on the
Cape I think it's cool spider-man
doesn't wear a cape hey guys who are you
I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from another another
dimension how many more spider people
are there hey tell us this could
literally not get any weirder it can get
weirder
my name is Peter Parker I'm supposed to
save the whole world you can't think
about saving the world you have to think
about saving one person miles where did
you go spider-man turn invisible not in
my universe this isn't some kind of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you talking about
holy mission
we are still in me
[Music]
seriously dad
Walken would have been fine
I mean this guy swings in once a day zip
zap zop in his little mask and answers
to motive right yeah dad yeah I love you
miles no no dad dad I love you
doctor copy Oh axe electing a bagel
spider-man
you know that's funny I get that a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look where you wanted to hit
[Music]
double tap to release and flip it out
again we're a little tease me as the
teacher who could still do it you as the
student who can do just not if good I'm
proud of us Peter
[Music]
Wow
hey guys Wanda it's Gwen actually oh you
know her very cool
I'm from another dimension I mean
another another dimension hey guys
Wanda it's Gwen actually oh you know her
very cool I'm from another dimension I
mean another another dimension all right
people let's start at the beginning
my name is Gwen Stacy for the last two
years I've been the one and only
spreader grunt during the band save my
dad
one day this weird thing happened and I
mean like really weird
I was blown into last week literally
landed in New York but not mine New York
let's go how many more spotty people are
there significant cuts my name is Peter
Parker I'm pretty sure you know the rest
I saved the city fell in love then I
saved the city again and again and again
look I'm a comic book serial I get a
Christmas album and it's soso popsicle
but this isn't about me not anymore
spider-man swings in once the days
except stopping his little masks and
answers to no one I love you mines dad
are you serious I wouldn't hear it dad I
love you better gosh
my name is Miles Morales I'm the one and
only spider-man at least that's what I
thought yep you hit the super collider
you did all of this
you're like me that's impossible
all right kids listen up this part is
your universe saga it's weird it's gross
and this delicious normal fry is my
universe so you want to learn to be
spider-man
Keeney teacher yes I can time to swing
good doing it double tap turtle ease and
quit that out again whip and release
your natural
hey guys who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm
from another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey fella this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weird okay we
need to get back to our universes soon
workload is going to collapse my family
lives in Brooklyn what's wrong this was
never your see
[Music]
it's my if I don't destroyed the
collider none of us will have a home to
go home soon
remember what makes you different let's
hope is what makes you spider-man
officer I love you do animals talk in
this dimension cuz I don't want to freak
him out my name is Peter Parker
[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse what a
pink I'm right here okay seriously dad
walking would have been fine breaking
news spider-man saves the day against
spider-man this guy swings in once the
day zip zap zop guys don't cops run red
lights well some do but uh not your dad
in your universe there's only one
spider-man but there's another universe
it looks it sounds like yours but it's
not my name is Miles Morales
thank you like me come around his time I
know it's complicated I know what
happened to you I can teach you to be
spider-man burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the spark in you it's amazing
paired up whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be great
I love you miles yeah I know that you
gotta say I love you back how do you
serious I want to hear it you want to
hear dad I love you gotta calm down the
swing just like I thought when did you
teach me that I didn't it's a little
joke the team-building
hey guys okay who are you I'm Gwen Stacy
come on my spider people are there send
us a comic-con what's coming so
[Music]
this morning I woke up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait so how many of us have you
[Music]